como reverter esteatose hepática grau do
que que é esteatose hepática pessoal é o
acúmulo moderado no caso do grau dois né
Se fosse grau um seria acúmulo leve de
gordura no fígado então pode ser
revertido através de mudança estilo de
vida principalmente na dieta atividade
física então é importante cortar
elementos industrializados processados
refinados açúcares carboidratos em geral
cortar gorduras artificiais fazer
atividade física especialmente os
aeróbicos caminhada e também musculação
ou funcional a estratégia de Reduzir a
gordura hepática é importante para
reduzir ou melhorar a sensibilidade à
insulina e combater a inflamação Ok
então reduzir a resistência insulínica e
melhorar a sensibilidade insulina a
perda de peso é fundamental você tem que
reduzir pelo menos 7% do Peso corporal
isso tem efeitos positivos na redução da
gordura dieta inflamatória que eu já
comentei
opte por alimentos de baixo índice
glicêmico eu falei da veia em um vídeo o
pessoal não entendeu o que eu tava
falando já meteram o pau no vídeo mas
aveia de modo geral é interessante pra
maioria das pessoas feijão maçã com
casca hortaliças e proteínas magras
combinação de exercícios aeróbicos com
ex de força e isso tudo comprovadamente
essa Associação de medidas é o que mais
vai ter peso na redução da gordura
intrahepática mesmo que você não perca
muito peso Às vezes você não pede tanto
peso assim mas só de você fazer
atividade física a gordura sai do fígado
e vai pro subcutâneo que é uma gordura
muito mais saudável Ok então na
abordagem integrativa você pode usar o
caro Mariano né que é o chá interessante
que é a fonte da cim Marina que é
protetor hepático você pode usar cúrcuma
também ter uma ação antiinflamatória
você pode usar o dente de leão que é
desintoxicante tem também o cachofra a
suplementação com vitaminas da família e
prente tocotrienóis ômega-3 vai ajudar
faça com Orientação médica e é muito
importante eh eu sei que é óbvio mas tem
que falar que é importante você evitar o
álcool porque é essencial isso para
evitar piora do
quadro e obviamente se você tem
o fígado gordo né a esteatose é muito
comum você ter resten insulínica
pré-diabetes pressão alta despideme
Então tem que tratar tudo isso em
conjunto né uma parte integrante do
tratamento manejo de estresse manejo da
do da questão do sono é muito importante
então é muito importante você
personalizar o seu plano e fazer uma
avaliação de toxicidade corporal e uma
avaliação de microbioma intestinal se
for indicado OK boa sorte para você ah
antes de encerrar eh exames
interessantes ult trol do fígado e se
tiver uma esteatose mais acentuada
muitos casos é importante fazer
elastografia para avaliar o grau de
fibrose do óg OK boa sorte